[Music]
well you remember michael cohen he was a
lawyer in new york he was once the
president's lawyer a couple of years ago
michael cohen was indicted for tax
evasion among other things
and he went to prison when the topic of
michael cohen comes up the one thing
everyone who knows michael cohen can
agree on the one thing
is that he's a sleazeball not a minor
sleazeball
but an epic sleazeball a hollywood level
sleazeball
if they ever make sleazeball the movie
michael cohen will play the lead and
he'll be in every sequel too
he'll have to be he was born for that
role so it's interesting to note that
among michael cohen's close
personal friends is an anchor on the
cable news network and not just
any cnn anchor but the cnn anchor given
to the most
overheated possible moral lectures the
first guy on that channel
to invoke god himself and the blessed
mother if necessary
as he scolds you for not living up to
his high ethical standards
that man's name is christopher charles
cuomo son of one governor
brother of another yale graduate weight
lifter
deeply good person and also we now learn
a buddy of michael cohen's
we know this because we have an audio
tape of a conversation between the two
men apparently there are
many tapes like this but tonight we're
going to play you just a portion
of one before you listen to this try to
remember what chris cuomo sounds like
when you watch him on television you've
seen him admit it then compare
that version that memory the official
morally inflated chris cuomo
to the guy you hear in this recording
here you go you know i'm always
careful when i talk to media you know
right
do you know how many phone calls i've
gotten from people at abc who say that
reporters
are calling and lying about things they
heard about me to try to get stories
about me when i was at abc
guys calling and saying i heard he was
the charlie rose of abc used to invite
women to the hotel and open his
uh bathroom do i look like the kind of
guy who's got to do that
sure why not um but
so i already have a good source that
says that he forced one woman to have
sex i just want to know if you've ever
heard anything like that
there is no woman right there is none of
this so here's the problem women who do
work there saying oh yeah you know
some of these men and naming me with
other guys you know we bumped on
to each other once in the elevator and
he put his hand on my shoulder and he
made me really
uncomfortable i mean what though
it's a problem and now you saw i'm
careful with the media always i've
always told you the media is not your
friend
no whoa well there's a lot to unpack
here but the first thing you notice is
that chris chrome was agitated he's mad
really mad and you know what makes him
maddest of all
the suggestion that he's got to act like
some old guy charlie rose to get the
ladies
sandbagging women in hotel rooms with an
open bathrobe
do i look like the kind of effing guy
who's got to do that he asks his pal
michael cohen
cohen's response sure why not open
bathrobes seem normal to michael cohen
but chris cuomo disagrees
chris combo doesn't need cheesy tricks
like that chris crumble is on television
chris cuomo could bench press your
subaru open bathrobes are for losers
chris cuomo is not a loser but you know
who is a loser
big time all those women who keep
accusing chris cuomo of sexual
harassment
they claim he bothered them in elevators
now
if women made those claims against you
chris cuomo might very well denounce you
on his tv show call for your firing call
for your banishment from decent society
these are women making the charges after
all you must
believe women women's voices must be
heard me too and all that
but that is not what chris cuomo tells
his friend michael cohen not even close
you get the sense as you listen that
neither one of these guys is a big
feminist
when chris and michael get together they
can let their hairs down and be
themselves
so chris spares michael the me too
lecture he doesn't say anything about
women's voices nothing
flattering anyway instead he says and
we're quoting here i mean
what the f in other words these girls
they're crazy
all of them want a piece of chris cuomo
maybe some of them want to get bench
pressed if you know what i mean
so they're making up these crazy lies
you know like women do
hormones probably but michael cohen is
not convinced by this explanation
even michael cohen takes women more
seriously than that
well it's a problem cohen begins to say
but chris cuomo cuts him off
when you're talking to chris cuomo you
don't actually get to talk much so
unfortunately we never learn
who are all these women who claim
they've been sexually harassed by chris
cuomo
what are their names have they received
financial settlements from cnn or abc
well we asked those questions yesterday
to cnn we sent them the tape you just
heard
we sent it to someone at the pr
department called matt dornek as well as
to that weird kid who hosts the media
show
they didn't respond was their reaction
the same as chris cuomo's i mean what
the f
we could only guess maybe they think
women are crazy too chris cuomo hasn't
called us either and you can see why
we work in the media and if there's one
thing that chris cuomo hates
it's the media though obviously he
defends the media night after night on
his show but he doesn't mean it not at
all
as he told his old pal michael cohen
more than once
i've always told you the media is not
your friend
actually we're starting to like chris
cuomo